ok so weit links am rand ich jetzt so
gelebt die decke geflogen
hey freunde und herzlich willkommen
zurück bei der epic poker mario tischen
zusammen mit pommes hdh die hall of
warcraft freuen
wir sind hier immer noch bei der stelle
ist ja auch nichts anderes passiert oder
so also wir sind immer noch hier und
letzte folge meinen koffer wieder sehr
witzig ist vielleicht auch eine
überlänge
okay wir müssen jetzt hier auf jeden
fall erst mal rüberkommen und zwar
kriegen wir hier immer sprung versteck
und ich wollte immer direkt runter wenn
ich sprung verstecken auch weil ich die
ich bekomme beim ersten sprung ich weiß
nicht warum ich habe jetzt so gehe ich
hier noch auf dem rand davon hier
weitermachen
ich habe jetzt bin jetzt hier auf dem
land ich bin jetzt hier springen jetzt
will der blog online
das soll ich schaffe es nicht vergessen
hast du beim ersten sprung ja langsam
fliegen schicken die scheiße okay die
kam ein scheiß auf deinen ganzen
theorien ist also überhaupt stehen leute
ihr könnt das einmal in die kommentare
was er in seinem leben nicht ich schreib
im tanz mach mal in die kommentare
mensch da bin ich mal gespannt und du
freust dich natürlich auch über die
happy go back to explode weil dieses
ausnahmslose click to explore
ich halte der bro denkst doch nicht im
ernst immerhin ist er leiter für dich
ich denke mehr tätig darunter schubsen
wollte gäste scheiße ich bin dennoch in
rückstand wie viele punkt da ist
überhaupt 4
nein woher hälfte war der zweite nur die
zwei vom anfang dass du denn jetzt ein
opfer waren keine punkte drin gerade
nein lag ist der gerade bilder gefunden
hat nein aber kein okay maybe you know
that you need to run lag der zweite
world hoch überhaupt einfach durchlaufen
ganz einfach eigentlich mal kommen
nochmal bitte wie viele punkte dass ich
finde das so schön anzuhören ich habe
ein punkt als einen punkt
ich habe einen punkt
also wenn ich hier keine truhe ist dann
fresse ich einen besen ok wette gilt
nein nein nein
blogs blog.com einer der blogger
mindestens 10.000 witz unser ziel am
anfang war nicht
auf einmal kam der rot-rote sterben das
ding zum hoch und dann sah ich das war
ein gummi und ich sah dass es gut war
und ich bin komplett herunter gefallen
ich hasse diese leiter springt richtig
und überall sind leitern und grüne
wollen
wie hoch das geht ja ok gemacht nein
nicht
welcome to the last level kiste
prinzessin wie schon am ende
burger
die kakteen alter taktik ausgedacht
die 123 ja die 123 taktik 1 200 springen
123 de hat geklappt
dass dann die branche zählweise es in
visual am ende kommt ne quatsch
man hört nur eine tastatur die ganze
nacht so das hier ist nur dass
prinzessin level sag ich mal wir müssen
hier irgendwie feature wie die heißt
befreien und dann kommen wir erst später
zum also es geht weiter
die apple von den gut
ich hänge mich immer noch bei den
kakteen und 25 das ist ein hartes
geschäft um die punkte herum
ich habe auch auf dich gewartet naja ich
habe den scheck von geöffnet
rettet unsere träume schaffen kommen
diese allen freut mich der wasserball
der wasserfall gedachter hoch können dir
ich könnte mir jetzt nicht du okay dann
warte ich auch nicht okay ich kann mir
aber vater okay achtung knochen ja fast
getroffen hast du brauchst kein check
point mehr okay du holst schon wieder
auf ich bin dein kleinen vorsprung mir
davon hier gerne mal haben metro metro
natur eine rakete
wenn ich da wieder die tour führte sind
ihr wiederkommen
die können wir uns mal wegen wenn du
auch dabei wild 2 durch die aufnahme
dann können wir uns dann die rakete
dann wartet einmal ganz gut da ich bin
die ganze zeit nur durch springen und
hole dich trotzdem nicht eine ja ja okay
ich warte oben beim schild vielleicht
habe ich da noch eine truhe
ja ich bin da wo bist du hinter dir
ich habe gedacht ich hab mich beeilt nur
weil ich was von von der rakete gesagt
ab deswegen hast du dich bei hds
richtiges loch hat mich oder geschossen
boa glück plötzlich stand ein skelett
muss sogar hierdurch wanna make it to
the scary lockdown der rakete zu ende
die luft da oben gerade schön frisch
dafür in die luft relativ warst du
geschützt das hat mich auch getroffen
herrlich auch ja das habe ich auch
gesagt man ja wer denn sonst
jetzt aber mal nachhakt oder doch okay
du acht leute die rakete für die folge 1
die gtg dreck kommt ich jetzt gelernt
mich jetzt in der gegen die decke
geflogen sein kopf ist gestorben
seriös bleiben aus navi ist bei ihnen
die darf man ihn so die aktien
ich habe ja pommes bei lieber seriös
bleiben
ich habe frei und das bild hier auch
allein schon weil es erstmal gehen
sollte gesetzt hast du ich hab den zoo
gesetzte kate will weiter springen aber
wohl lang hat er jetzt epischer lukas
lacko armenischer gongschlag will dein
leben alter alter geht's hier runter
ja man jetzt nur glas ich dachte schon
oh ja in etwa acht so wir müssen jetzt
in das ganze wasser hier einspringen ich
guck gerade ob ich die ränkespiele
natürlich auf dem rand gehören dir die
hand herz schlägt immer gut
klasse rand von der pizza ein verein
kommt will ich immer darauf dem
kommt schuldig da immer auf die pizza
darauf an ich finde bei manchen pizza
schmeckt auch daran gut
ja aber dann einen drei monate alten
vergammelten b 27 ich muss hier
rotterdam aber wir müssen ihnen wohne in
einer höhle finden die in bühl verbandes
herunterkommen
das merken da dann das wasser müssen
springt da ehrlich da war jedoch
gefallen sein
shechtman der compilation erstellen wo
kommen die ganze zeit nur hinfällt nein
glaube das ist falsch
da waren wir schon wir müssen jetzt wie
gesagt die höhle finden
hier wollen wir noch nicht weiß noch
über hier warte man warte mal ich hab
knochen
daraus kann ich mir knochenmehl machen
und damit kann ich mir ganz coole sachen
macht geht nicht
ich dachte irgendwie pilz ja kein plan
da hinten waren wir schon hier war mir
schon überall weinten leder aber nein da
man auch schon im baum hochgeklettert
gleich sagt er wir nächste folge geht es
dabei komme weiter nur drei minuten
wir wollen auf jeden fall in cave in
oder so da warte ich schon mal ganz kurz
noch mal was da oben war alle gamer will
ich jetzt mach mal eben nur lausanne du
du nimmst nicht auf ich auch nicht weil
ich weiß wie ich das installieren
kleinen bildschirm vor schwierige
eigentlich nicht ich meine wäre es
wieder spucken können hat also da oben
stand er meinte ja findet jetzt die höhe
das theoretisch mussten wir da oben
drauf springen das heißt wahrscheinlich
kannst du einfach kein englisch erwarte
ich lese hier nochmal vor
down the line freundliche leading to wed
2 wir müssen wahrscheinlich jetzt hier
runter springen wahrscheinlich doch da
oben drauf bleibe ich kam auch mal zu
dir nicht darum dass wir unten
aber ja genau hier dass hier irgendwas
eine höhle sein soll
wir sollen jetzt hier in kelvin
eigenartig ich habe also wo ja ja wo das
ist die frage wenn du kannst ja selber
mal nach oben gehen und dich davon
überzeugen dass man englisch richtig war
war richtig glaubt einfach mal spannen
nicht den bogen könnte ich mir für
später für meine folge
egal wo wo ist bitte die cave wird das
kay wahrscheinlich so richtig
offensichtlich wir laufen schon tausend
mal vorbei ich schon mal ganz kurz was
da oben jetzt ein schild stand oder
fliegt genau die am stauwehr in find the
cave leading to the wall
hier haben wir doch das soll ist es
direkt neben w2 aber was ist die 2 ich
meine das war das sehen wo wir beim
einer folge ganz lange gefehlt hat
spinnen und zombies verfolgen aber es
stimmt wenn hier schon die fas
allerdings ist dadurch sicher um gleich
wahrscheinlich einfach zwischen diesen
lama ding das da irgendwie butt ist oder
so weil das werder steht world world 1
bis 3 oder tempels abgesperrt also mein
konnte er einen tempel rein aber ich
weiß nicht wie
so könnt ihr also ich habe auf jeden
fall einschaltet habe ich weiß nicht wie
du hast du schalter ja ja soll mensch ja
dann
er sagt aber wo warst du hast ein
scheitern der gebotenen glaube ich
glaube hier hinten fleisch
irgendwie zieht mich darum hier magisch
an weiß nicht nur eine trikot macht mich
an
übrigens freunde ihr könnt ja
theoretisch mal schon wieder vorschläge
machen für eventuelle adventure maps die
ein bisschen länger dauern
die man auch so jump'n'run oder
irgendwie sowas kommt weiß blaue brille
gefunden
ja genau mal schön karten vorschlag weil
wir planen da was cooles sag ich mal auf
jeden fall denke ich auf jeden fall noch
weiter lustige folgen gebe ich finde
triumph spitfire die vku
so wartete schalter wo muss ich den
schalter endlich ich würde den nebel
neben dem jetzt machen nix falsch ist
yaman kisten
ich würde so wechsele ich schlag dich
einfach
wie wir einfach unsere was ich gar nicht
bin bereit
da bringt man und beide total ruhig war
es auch zu bränden bitte nein
schade wir werden auf jeden fall nicht
einfacher doch wird schon auch ich bin
nicht geschafft mach jetzt du hast bei
mir ist wiederum achso und diese
volksschüler vorbei die nächste folge
dann wieder mit mit geistreichen fails
und einer fetten range hdr dann aber wie
kommt man denn da drüber ich habe keine
places places okay das ist okay so coach
für die geistig an die exit gut
ihr seht das ganze sache dann in der
nächsten folge bei comma hd die man ins
euch gefallen hat einen daumen hoch
geben könnte in die kommentare schreiben
welche adventure eventuell länger dauern
wo man auftanken kann und com ist
natürlich auch näher beschreiben wenn
ihr nicht abonniert seit die total
bescheuert einfach nur danke danke das
war kein kompliment 51 euro kriegst du
später hertie habe ich auch schon
gekriegt nochmal 50
die alte john webb weißt du ach so für
den partner vor ja dann tschüss ich
möchte mein geld